bang-bang what's up guys lunch money
time
what's a Tuesday while Wall Street's
trying to get rich the rest of us just
trying to get our lunch money right I am
here with the beautiful intelligent
plain Tamara Nova or also known as Walt
Disney I have no clue why she has on a
tie-dye Mickey shirt my mom gave you
that oh it's probably to see if you were
actually gonna wear it or not so now
she's got proof wait she really gave you
that yeah I'll have a conversation with
my mother we don't need that type of
fashion going on around here black
t-shirts only this is a uniform
violation all right what's going on with
the having you spoiled it right um we
have have we have have yes the bitcoin
having it has haven't okay do you
remember what it means yes what um
the mining stuff gets cut in half the
number of incoming Bitcoin yeah from how
many oh oh from 21 million no there's 21
million total from 8,000 no oh - 900 -
900 is correct but from 1800 1850
percent drop so the Bitcoin having
occurred the third ever it's basically
if you understand quantitative easing
easing which is basically the printing
of more money devaluing a currency think
of the Bitcoin having as quantitative
hardening right is actually less and
less supply being being put into the
system very similar to what would happen
if today the Federal Reserve decided to
go in the opposite direction of what
they're doing it would over time
actually make the currency more valuable
so that occurred yesterday we went from
1800 Bitcoin a day to 900 we are off to
the races four years from now we will
get another having but I think it was
just a big deal that it actually
occurred you said that what happened in
like 120 years like all the Bitcoin will
be mined so think of like half-life in
science right the half-life is you know
periodically every time it cuts in half
that's basically what's happening with
Bitcoin starting at 50 Bitcoin 25 12 and
a half six point two five hundred going
it'll take all the way till 2000 140 the
year 21
40 for it to actually have all of the 21
million bitcoins out into the system
long time crazy boy will we be around to
see that I'll be 151 years old I will be
but you'll be cryogenically frozen so
you might be woo bang bang alright
what's going on with kwibi this is my
favorite story we said how much money
before it even launched all right so
what happened kwibi is a short form
video it's the whole idea of 10 minutes
or less and you watch it on your phone
and they literally raised 1.8 billion
dollars to go do this now there's two
people behind it that are very very
intelligent very successful Jeffrey
Katzenberg and Meg Whitman but every
single millennial that ever heard about
this idea literally said why do I need
that that's not going to work they
raised 1.8 billion dollars how many
downloads did they get so it's a paid
app even with a nine a free 90-day trial
that has been installed by only 2.9
million customers they claim it's 3.5
million but the data analytics firm say
2.9 so either way it's around three to
three and a half million 1.8 billion
dollars they got 3 million downloads
this is comical guess what the excuses
as to why has it worked so Jeff
Katzenberg goes I attribute everything
that has gone wrong to coronavirus
everything and then when the reporter
said well what about tick tock has been
downloaded 2 billion times
he said that's like comparing apples and
submarines you can't can't compare that
they're not the same yes they are
literally they're watching videos on
their phone dummy so though I mean look
this end by the way like I actually
think that Jeff Katzenberg is incredibly
smart I think made weapons incredibly
incredibly smart but this is a classic
problem of where arrogance takes over
just because you've been successful
before doesn't mean you're gonna be
successful now and again if you remember
the lunch money episode where we talked
about this previously I can only think
of one company ever that raised hundreds
of millions or billions of dollars
pre-product being launched and ended up
being successful and that was jet comm
and jet combo by Walmart mainly because
they wanted Marc lor to go work there
but other than that I can't think of a
single company that has been able to
raise hundreds of millions of billions
of dollars what's the other company
that's magically getting crushed as well
they try to sell the company in a fire
skirt it wasn't a fire sale they try to
sell for ten billion dollars nobody bid
and so now they're like basically
selling it off in parts to laying off
their staff like that every time you see
companies raise tons and tons of money
before they ever launched the product it
almost never works so here's the thing I
can see how they're thinking got them
here because they thought we're
literally gonna call every single
celebrity I know because Jeffrey
Katzenberg basically has access to all
of them I remember a report somebody
said if you didn't get a if you're a
celebrity you didn't get a call from
Jeff for the four kwibi like are you
even famous so basically it was kind of
like a popularity contest they all got
on there it was supposed to be high
quality content maybe it is high quality
content but people aren't watching
it's like luminary if anybody heard of
this company called luminary they had a
very similar strategy which was the
whole idea was be the Netflix for
podcast so basically you'd pay 10 bucks
and you get all these podcasts over
behind a paywall very some of the
Netflix and what they did is they
wouldn't got a bunch of celebrities and
they said hey you celebrities why don't
you create content behind the put it
behind this pay wall but nobody really
signed up like it didn't work and again
it's the same thing it's the wrong
product I don't care how famous people
are behind a paywall if it's the wrong
part if people don't want that then they
are not going to pay for it and the
reason why this doesn't work is you have
people who they're very very smart
they've been very successful in their
life but what got you here isn't
necessarily gonna get you there right
and you can't sit and look at all
because I've been so successful in the
past
that means I'm a genius and I understand
what's going on now it's a new game this
digital world it's screwing up all of
these legacy players they don't know
what to do they're literally there's
youtubers who have bigger audiences that
all of the nightly shows is oh this is
from Millennials this is what
Millennials do dude do you realize
Millennials are like in their 30s you're
talking about Gen Z that should be your
target demographic yeah well that's why
it's it's like one like it's over it's
over K Oh game over
tick-tock one on the mobile video front
and here's the thing is it'll be easier
for a tick-tock to actually go from what
is it a minute long video or 30-second
video whatever the hell they have to 5
or 10 minute videos then it will be four
kwibi to get any penetration of the
market oh really
yes nice agree must be because you have
on that Walt Disney shirt this is where
you say it's not a Walt Disney shirt
it's a Walt Disney it created Mickey
Mouse do you know that he hand drew
Mickey Mouse official yeah do you know
that he hand drew it did you know that
he used to hand draw a Minnie Mouse as
well and he was like that's how the
cartoon yeah anyway
Elon is asking to be arrested Elon Musk
is a gangster straight up period like
the dude said you know what I'm not
playing this game anymore there's
federal laws state laws and local laws
they don't agree with each other on what
you should do around reopening your
business and so Elon said I'm gonna
reopen my business and not only am I
going to reopen the business but again
as we talked in the past about good
leadership he said I'm not gonna ask my
workers to do anything that I'm
unwilling to do I'm gonna go work on the
front line with them in the factory and
if the cops want to show up they can
come arrest me I have a question how is
it that when you have conflicting laws
on the federal state and local level mmm
how are you supposed to know what to
follow well that that's the one of the
big challenges here it's like marijuana
laws right like so technically marijuana
is illegal at the federal level but in
Colorado for example it's not right or
you even get a place like take baltimore
baltimore actually it is illegal on the
books that for marijuana right and at
the federal level it's illegal but what
the district attorney has said is i'm
not going to enforce the law i BIST I'm
gonna decriminalize it through
enforcement not by changing the law so
basically what's happening here is Elon
is calling their bluff he said okay cool
you guys are you're Alameda County the
county local county people you're gonna
come arrest me okay fine I'll see on the
on the floor now what's really
interesting about this though
his factories are very high-tech they've
got tons of robot stuff so he actually
has lower amount of people in there than
most car factories would have but on top
of that he's willing to go on the front
lines and so are the workers well so
here's what's interesting we watched an
interview with Chema this morning where
he said it appears to me that the county
officials don't want to sit down with
him and have a conversation about okay
you want to open your factory how are
you gonna do it safely how are you gonna
test people are you gonna wear masks
like all that stuff instead they're kind
of just shunning him and saying we don't
even want to have a conversation with
you and we're gonna say f you on Twitter
here's what the world is learning is
somebody like Elon Musk has more money
in a bigger audience than the media or
the politicians Elon Musk has more power
than they have and what power is
audience right now what Elon Musk is
doing is Elon Musk is playing a game
that the politicians can't win and the
whole thing is that there is a very
large percentage of the population of
the citizens of the United States who
agree with Elon Musk and he knows that
and so what he's basically doing is he's
calling the bluff of the politicians
because any politician that steps in and
arrests Elon Musk
there's careers over right and he's
basically saying you're being dumb and
normally we would have to sit back and
play by your rules but I am in a
position where I can push back and this
is the beauty of a democracy right is
that not any one group has total power
so people check Elon Musk's power right
the politicians have their power check
law enforcement has their power check
the media has their power Cheston you're
kind of saying that I'm not saying that
because they could go arrest him but
there's consequences to taking that
action it's a very complex system and
there's checks and balances throughout
the whole thing but again do you want to
go arrest a guy who he actually has a
safety plan in place it's not like he's
saying hey everyone just go back they
have social distancing they have masks
like they're taking a bunch of
precautions his point is your rules are
dumb of course because his other Factory
is actually okay so it's okay for one
factory to be open in the state but not
in another state right it's all stupid
it's all stupid so one last thing that's
really important here though I think is
on top of all this I saw this as
BuzzFeed reporter I'm gonna name who he
is but
just absolute stupidity right like he's
the classic person who just wants to
attack people and billionaires and
investors all this kind of stuff and he
said oh haven't you ever seen Evon must
do anything that isn't self-serving
right the only reason why he wants to
open this is because it's self-serving
but what people forget is Yvonne mas
runs a publicly traded company that has
shareholders those shareholders are
depending on the company to produce a
product that is sold so they can drive
revenue so they can drive a profit so
the share price increases and they can
make a return that's the whole point of
business and so this whole idea of like
oh this is just for the individual
benefit of Elon Musk that's not gonna
say oh I don't care about rich people
making money and how about 55% of
Americans that own stocks what are
usually just screw them to because the
government's coming to save you I I tend
to agree with you here but I don't want
to get into semantics
Salima doesn't like all the political
side all right grocery cost wait one
more thing about you do you think you'll
actually get arrested no you don't think
so it it would be career suicide for a
politician and Elon Musk would go from
well-liked on the Internet to literally
like the internet Hall of Fame there's a
photo of you on a factory in handcuffs
are you kidding me but don't you think
it's also political suicide to not carry
out what you have mandated no because
nobody actually believes that the
politicians believe what they're saying
like the politicians are saying things
it's like Bill DeBlasio Bill DeBlasio
saying that protests aren't banned in
New York City he's doing that for
personal benefit Andrew Cuomo clown town
literally the things that he's saying is
all for political benefit people see
again the virus is exposing the shams of
society and people realize that what is
happening is the politicization of the
virus and the economic crisis they don't
want to help the people they literally
are doing it for power and control
because if you want to help the people
you know what you would do you would
actually help the people by giving them
money you would reopen the economy in a
certain in a very intelligent and safe
way you would do the things that are
necessary to actually provide benefit
but instead what we have is we have a
government that wants the people to be
more dependent on all right let's not
talk about politics anymore grocery cars
junk the most and 46 years led by rising
prices for meat and eggs actually I have
a
oh sorry about this I went to the
grocery store twice in one week
no I she three times in two weeks when I
wasn't here so there is a meat or a beef
shortage that's why we had chicken
meatballs yesterday huh
she made chicken meatballs and tried to
pass him off as meatballs I said well
you can't call them chicken meatballs
because they're just chicken balls no
they're our meatballs chicken is me yeah
but they're chicken balls no yeah what
are those beef balls yeah would that you
usually make a meatball with beef
chicken balls but you wanna make sausage
balls so listen the rising prices for
meat and eggs here's what's really
interesting this is all happening in a
deflationary environment
so obviously the supply and demand if
there's a shortage of us of a supply
then and demand stays constant arises
price will go up that's what's happening
right here yeah so we're seeing a huge
increase in prices how big is the
percentage increase 2.6 percent so it's
high but it's not super super high yet
if we were an inflationary environment
where the dollar was being devalued
against meat eggs and other groceries
then all of a sudden you would have more
social unrest this is what's happening
in Lebanon is in Lebanon they literally
are having that carsi devalued and the
food prices are exploded but use a
deflationary environment are we in
inflationary we're in a deflationary
environment because the dollar is
getting stronger and so this is a
nuanced it over a long period of time if
you print money it will lead to an
inflationary environment but in the
short term the reason why they have to
print so much money is because we're in
a deflationary environment there's a
need that the easiest way to think about
deflation is everyone wants dollars
right they want the safety of dollars
they want that the peace of mind of
dollars so they look around and everyone
says where of the dollars but there's
not enough dollars available right in
all these different forms and markets
and so the government steps in says oh
we don't have enough dollars I'll print
a bunch more dollars and put them into
the market in all these different places
so that now I can satisfy the need for
dollars right so we can go from a
deflationary environment back to
inflationary because
deflation nobody spends everyone holds
the assets you need inflation to spur
economic activity right that's the
thought process and so literally if we
had the inflationary environment right
now in food costs going up there would
be social unrest just like you're seeing
in Lebanon because people wake up and
they say I don't have enough mind of to
afford food that's crazy so thankfully
we're in the deflationary environment
while there's a shortage hopefully what
will happen is that the shortage of food
will go away once there's easier trade
transportation and everything after the
Crone virus you feel like you've got a
crash course in food economics what you
always ask that I'm smart I know you're
smarter than I am okay I am sure you I
can't take you seriously when you have a
Mickey Mouse shirt on all right what's
going on with so AMC shares are soaring
50 percent on record slash rumors that
they've had buyout talks with Amazon
it's important to know that this is an
unconfirmed report by the Daily Mail
which is a British tabloid but all these
other media organizations are
investigating it nobody from Amazon or
AMC s talking but the shares of AMC are
shooting through the roof what are they
gonna do if they buy them take over the
world okay could you imagine a world
where the Amazon owns movie theatres and
they're like you know what I don't move
the theater you can watch all the crap
you want to watch but we're gonna
discount our movies that's one way to
think about it the so there they've done
this playbook before right Amazon was
getting into grocery and then they went
they bought physical retail space with
Whole Foods as of Massa is like 13
billion dollar acquisition they've now
gotten very very heavily into movies so
they've got two types of things that one
is Amazon Prime video you can go on that
should have a pretty good selection of
movies if you're a Prime member or
things like a hundred bucks a year or
whatever you can get access to it but
second is they've made a ton of
investment in amazon original studios
which is how they make a lot of the
original series
so them and Netflix are fighting it out
to create this stuff it would be super
interesting for three things one if they
said we are going to release all of our
originals in AMC places first so the
only way to watch this to go and be MC
why do they want people to go physically
in person because there are some people
who still will go in person to is they
could say you actually if your name is
on Prime member you can go for free or
for a massive discount saying the prime
business is incredible if you look at
Amazon Prime or Costco's model where
they have you know sixty to a hundred
dollar type annual memberships these
businesses print money and so all
they're trying to do is pull more value
behind that Prime membership and then
the other thing that they could say is
movie theaters are so antiquated we're
just gonna come at it with a better
technological you know perspective and
we're gonna drastically improve the
experience and get people back in a
socially distanced well don't worry in
New York chromo said that drive-in movie
theaters are open for business or their
drive-in movie theaters in New York City
I don't not intensity I mean so yeah
just keep going what speaking of
corruption and Feith what about the bear
thief you stole people's freedom I am is
there they're hurting small business
owners let the people go back to work
and make a living by the wave Andrew
Cuomo was a real leader he'd give up a
salary until small businesses could go
back to work yeah think about small
businesses he extended the lockdown till
June 6th I believe so almost three full
months
Andrew Cuomo is getting been getting
paid and taking his salary for 90 days
while he shut down the ability for small
business owners to make a living
I saw leadership he shouldn't make a
living oh why are you asking your
constituents to do something you're
unwilling to do for yourself Elon Musk
is willing to go on the factory floor
and risk getting coronavirus it's open
his business okay 25 seconds what's
going on with the bear thing what is a
bear bear broke into this Gatlinburg is
I've been trying to see I think it is a
cabin and stole peanut butter cups as
menem's
Sour Patch Kids and beer this literally
sounds like you in a bear costume
literally sounds like my spirit animal
peanut butter cups
mmm Sour Patch Kids and beer oh yeah
yeah me and that bear would get along
can you imagine if you walked into the
woods and saw me no bear chillin just
drinking some beers and eating sour
patch kids cuz it's sweet it's the same
reason why humans are it's addicting
I've been thirsty taking two beers and
two diet cokes
Oh ooh he will hit you with two
alcoholics and two non-alcoholic drinks
these are smart bears they took medicine
it's a beer they took coke and it took
candy those guys are going to have a
party there is no social distancing
going on bear land these like bears
getting into candy I'd be like hey save
me some if they were getting the beer
hey chill out over there all right
listen you got to leave a couple for me
and you said something like like a worm
or a sloth or something a chameleon
exactly Kamille exactly you know why cuz
chameleons can be successful in any
environment fact they just they just
kind of move and shake they change their
colors you know do whatever they got to
do you know my favorite animal what you
know it what dolphin what what noise do
you think okay tell them a story very
quickly we ran out of time but tell them
story very quickly about when you went
to meet a dolphin cried oh my god so my
mom took me to the Bahamas because I
love dolphins
and we met a dolphin named Missy and I
got to pet her and like look into her
eyes and then she like splash me it was
like literally the best moment in my
life I can't even describe literally I
tried to do all kinds of nice things
were pulling then she wouldn't met a
dolphin and then all of my all of my
work was just erased from her memory you
do think misty misses Missy Missy misses
you yes and she was like such as social
dolphin that she would hang out with us
and then like swim away to go see what
her friends were doing and then be fine
and then come back
she needs to socially yeah all right go
follow Missy on a tick-tock I'm sure
she's got a [ __ ] tick-tock going
that's it for today for lunch money well
while she's trying to get rich I suppose
she's trying to get her lunch money
right we will talk to you guys tomorrow
bye